hey this is presh tallwalker
each of three bags contains only red or
blue balls
the first bag contains two red balls and
x squared minus six x plus thirteen blue
balls
the second bag contains three red balls
and x squared minus six x plus twelve
blue balls
the third bag contains four red balls
and x squared minus six x plus eleven
blue balls
a ball is drawn at random from a
randomly chosen bag
what is the maximum probability that the
drawn ball is red
i think amish for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
let's calculate the probability of
drawing a red ball from each of the
three bags
in the first bag there are two red balls
and a total of x squared minus 6x plus
15 balls
in the second bag there are three red
balls and this bag has the same total
number of balls
the third bag has four red balls and it
also has the same total number of balls
each of the three bags is equally likely
to be chosen so each bag has a one-third
chance of being drawn
we can thus calculate the probability
that the randomly chosen ball is read by
taking the weighted sum of these three
probabilities
it'll be one-third multiplied by the
probability of drawing a red ball from
the first bag plus one-third multiplied
by the probability of drawing a red ball
from the second bag plus one-third
multiplied by the probability of drawing
a red ball from the third bag
we can simplify the sum
each of the three terms have the same
denominator so we can group them into a
common denominator
we then add up the numerators
from here we factor one-third
then two plus three plus four is equal
to nine
one third of nine is equal to three
this is the probability that the
randomly chosen ball is red
we wanna maximize this probability to do
that let's look at the denominator x
squared minus 6x plus 15.
to analyze this function we'll complete
the square
we'll rewrite this as x squared minus x
plus nine plus six
the first three terms will simplify to
be x minus three the quantity squared
then we add six
we can analyze this function
for real values of x the quantity x
minus three squared is a non-negative
number and it reaches a minimum when x
is equal to three
at that point it'll be equal to zero
so this quadratic is greater than or
equal to zero plus six so it's greater
than or equal to six and that happens
when x is equal to three
now let's go back to the probability
we know that the denominator is greater
than or equal to six and it's at its
minimum value when x is equal to three
when the denominator is at its minimum
that's when the probability is that it's
maximum because we're dividing by the
minimum number
so the probability will be less than or
equal to three divided by six and that
simplifies to be one-half
thus the maximum probability is equal to
one-half and that happens when x is
equal to three
and that's the
answer thanks for making us one of the
best communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you